thank you
hey guys welcome back to my channel and
if you've not been here before remember
to subscribe I would love to support my
name is Daniel and today I'm doing video
requests the video request that I
received is this how to start working
out at a home for skinny guys alright
now a while ago I showed you my workout
routine and diet plan from going skinny
to muscle in just 10 weeks but that was
at the gym so how do you do it at home
with no weights well that's what I'm
going to tell you guys in this video all
you need to do is follow the workout
routine I'm gonna help you to get set up
at home I'm also going to give you the
diet plan at the end of this video now
remember this video is to gain muscle
not to lose weight so you won't find any
hit cardio here are you ready let's go
your first week will look like this day
one chest triceps back biceps and
shoulders day two legs and abs then all
you do is you just repeat those days for
the rest of the week meaning day three
will be the same as day one day four the
same as day two day five the same as day
one again and day six the same as day
two now the first week is only there to
get your body your muscles used to
working out before I go into specifics
let me just quickly explain to you how
the reps and sets are going to work day
one and two will be two sets of 10
repetitions for every exercise that is
your goal now every person is different
but if you're skinny you might not reach
it you might reach it and you might feel
like hey I can do actually more than
this but don't because you're going to
hurt your muscles only do two sets of 10
repetitions of every exercise just to
get your muscles used to working out day
three and four will be three sets of 10
repetitions for every exercise and then
day five and six will be four sets of 10
repetitions now the sets for the first
week is not that many because if we're
gonna
raise the number then it's just gonna
hurt you right and a lot of people when
they start working out they just go into
it full steam and then they hurt a lot
and then they think man is this what it
means to work out I don't want to do it
this is not fun this is painful
so going into this first week Full Steam
might hurt you so take it easy just get
yourself used to working out and then
the second week now that's when we get
more serious
for week two you will move from four
sets to five sets of every exercise
until muscle failure
that means you do every exercise every
set until your muscle basically fails
meaning you're trying to lift or do
something but you just can't because you
don't have the power to do it this is
the key to building muscle because you
want to push yourself as much as you can
this is why some guys build muscle and
some don't it's all because of effort
and consistency this is what I used to
do when I went from one modeling Market
one country to another when I wanted to
gain a little bit of weight and when I'm
talking about weight I don't mean fat I
mean muscle now let me show you the
specifics of the workouts you'll need a
following a workout towel for your sweat
earphones or headphones for music a
water bottle workout clothes and gym
gloves if your wife likes you to touch
her with soft pants
now to get faster results you can also
buy pre-workout and good whey protein
now if you're not sure what to get I
will add everything my favorites for you
in the video description down below so
you can go and check them out they're
there with their direct link so it'll
save you some time
now let's start with the workout routine
day one chest and triceps exercise one
decline push-ups this works the upper
chest for decline push-ups just get a
chair or a bench your hands will be
shoulder length from each other and
start from the floor your body should be
like a plank focus on your form and
don't cheat go all the way up and all
the way down and if you can't do the
incline push-ups just do normal push-ups
and if you struggle with that just bend
your knees and start from there if
you're very skinny don't worry about it
don't worry about where you start we all
have to start somewhere right just focus
on where you want to end up and work
towards that exercise 2 tricep dips get
a bench or a chair put your feet next to
each other knees Bend and push up with
your triceps go back down and do it
again now if this is too easy just get
something to put your feet up on and do
it again
exercise three bicep curls get two big
10 liters of water or you can also fill
some bags with rocks sand or any other
heavy stuff you can stand or sit your
choice keep your abs hard and your body
still
only your arms should move all the way
down and all the way up don't cheat or
swing your arms up because you will
overcompensate with your other muscles
and you might hurt yourself exercise
four shoulder pipes or that's what I
call it take the form as if you're going
to do a push-up but now bring your lower
body up and keep your back straight
almost as if your upper body is a spear
ready to be thrown into the ground
straight in front of you now all you do
is shoulder push-ups with a straight
back if this is too hard for you you can
use your weight bags and then you do
side and front shoulder raises move all
the way up and all the way down to the
side and to the front now later when
you're stronger you can also do both of
these exercises and also the classic
shoulder raises exercise five see if you
can find a spot to pull yourself up to
do pull-ups if you can't then just get a
towel lie on the ground straighten it
out and push the towel all the way out
and then bring it in underneath your
chin while using your upper body and
pushing your shoulder blades together
exercise six normal push-ups this is the
last exercise so here your body is
already tired and this is where you need
to push yourself in mind and in body
all the way to the end your body is not
going to want to do this your arms your
chest everything is tired and this is
where you just push yourself and say hey
I can do this
I need to force myself my muscles to
grow bigger to change you want your
muscle tissues to tear so that you can
realize that it needs to build back
stronger and better start on the ground
hands shoulder length or even a bit
closer because the Deep line push-ups
were shoulder length right and then all
you do is push up all the way and then
go back down and then just repeat
now that's it guys that's it for the
basic upper body workout and it's gonna
work now let's go to day two legs and
abs now personally I always start with
the ABS first because honestly it is
terrible to do abs while your legs are
already tired
first up is jackknives I stretch out all
the way and then raise up my lower and
upper body and touch my toes this is a
great workout
next up bicycles but not the traditional
bicycle workout because that just
doesn't work at all if you do this it
won't work you're just wasting time what
you need to do is this keep your feet
off the ground at all times hands behind
your head then when you move your right
elbow to the left knee keep your right
leg down until your left leg comes back
before you can move it to the left elbow
do one side first completely before you
start to move the other side
next up leg raises with a spin first
raise your legs to the sides in a bow
form while opening up
then bring them back the same way and
then raise them straight up go down and
just repeat
this workout works like a bomb you're
gonna feel it the next one is drunken
mountain climbers now I don't really
like planks at all it's not fun for me
to do
drunken mountain climbers are a lot
better moving to a platform and then
just move your one knee up and Below you
move it back and then the other one then
just repeat it and keep your abs hard
alright guys that's it for the apps next
legs first up lunges you can do this
with homemade weights or if you're not
strong enough yet just use your body
weight just find an area with enough
space and then all you do is right leg
forward bend the left knee and stand up
with the right leg muscles do the same
on the other side and then just repeat
calf raises are next you can use stairs
or anything that can get your feet off
the ground you can do it with homemade
weights or if you can't yet just use
your body weight one leg behind the
other then move all the way down and all
the way up and just repeat
next up squats bend down pump out almost
like you are going to sit on the toilet
feet shoulder length apart you need to
feel comfortable
back straight and then just move down
and up if it's too easy for you just use
your homemade weights or if you don't
have any homemade weights you can do one
leg squats above your couch like this
all right guys this is enough to get you
started as you continue to grow stronger
you can add some exercises but honestly
this is enough for you to see a
difference in the mirror
but now the most important thing is your
diet if you don't give your muscles what
it needs
then you're not going to see any
difference this is where a lot of people
don't understand I mean they they do all
the work they go to the gym they work
hard but they look the same you know
that guy he said a year ago or two years
ago no he's going to the gym every day
but he looks exactly the same this is
why to help you with your diet plan
check out this video here and it will
help you out
and remember if you haven't subscribed
yet please do so so you won't miss any
of our future videos where we're going
to show a lot more fitness and health
videos
now before you go always remember life
is short so don't waste yours Church
guys